bonsoir mais petite beauté enfin pour ce
soir on en après midi à 17h45 sans
décoller en ce moment j'ai l'impression
d'animer le club dorothée
vous avez vu on a enlevé tout ce qui est
mon salon donc et avons ajusté enlevé
donc là la table et le canapé et on est
en mode 100 évolueront en mode chaume
voilà voyons pas on n'est pas
franchement un jeu des boîtes
exceptionnel je vous le dis vous allez
pouvoir remporter jusqu'à 50000 euros
oui vous ne rêvez pas cinquante mille
euros à partager avec les hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france il ya 4 ni
lellouche qui jouera avec nous
expressément camille lellouche qui est
la star du moment c'est la taulière
c'est l'humoriste de l'année je vous le
dis je la dore camille lellouche est
avec nous ça va ma camille d'amour mois
c'est trop mignon merci de m'accueillir
comme ça tu vas jouer avec un jeune
homme qui est très mignon très beau
gosse on revient dessus d'ici là comment
comment tu t'es intitule mon chéri
messaoudène vous avez choisi la boîte
numéro 5 depuis le début où il ya des
piles dedans où il ya les 10000 euros
avant il y a notre charcutier trader
merzouk blanchard qui veut vous faire
une proposition
l'appli pb banque vous propose de vous
racheter votre boîte ont bien pour 3000
euros c'est sûr au mieux tu prends les
3000 euros c'est sûr et bien 3000 euros
pour camille lellouche
pour les autres et d'autre part
ile-de-france dans la boîte 0,5 et
shihri y avait déjà la coupe du monde
des débats c'est très simple quart de
finale demi-finale final c'est à dire
quatre matches ensuite y aura des demi
finales et des finales et participeront
à cette coupe du monde des débats rené
malleville et afida turner il y aura un
combat
matthieu delormeau afida turner sur la
tenue d'appliquer un plan d'ailleurs de
jeudi on va voir la tenue d'afida
regarder puisque c'est face à mathieu
qu'on va faire ce quatrième débat afida
turner face à matthieu delormeau
regardez il ya eu énormément de
critiques mais je dirais avant tout que
je suis là pour divertir les gens c'est
vrai qu'il ya des gens d'aujourd'hui qui
sont tous dans les hôpitaux et qui n'ont
pas la chance comme nous de pouvoir
faire des émissions au pouvoir regarder
le divertissement et donc j'avais envie
finalement d'égayer ce peuple français
est malheureusement au jour
d'aujourd'hui dans une terre est dans
une situation très délicate je suis venu
nous divertir dans ces cas là cyril
fallait qu'elle nous fasse rire là elle
est venue elle est venue pour nous
exposer les jaunes et les gones journal
disant que le chine où les chinois et
avec les mairies pour les américains
c'est pas un avis à un complot et je te
rappelle d'ailleurs cyril que je suis
devant son twitter elle a retweeté jean
marie le pen
donc si tu veux pour moi n'est pas venu
pour nous divertir elle est venue pour
donner un avis un avis politique qui à
mon sens d'abord est dangereux et tu
viens pas d'abord soutenir une théorie
du complot avec une coupe de champagne
et à maillot de bain avec des idées qui
sont sortis de ton décolleté avec un
mode bac qui rentrent dans la raie des
fesses pour pour convenir des 9% des
théories karine ferri a tout perdu
alors est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une ce serait une bonne décision de la
part de tf1 ou pas matthieu delormeau tu
penses quoi je pense que c'est aberrant
la part de tf1 parce que c'est illogique
d'abord ils ont tout fait pour la
pousser depuis des années l'ont mis dans
des documentaires fixe jamais l'auto la
même partout pour en faire le nouveau
visage après son deck et y est la jolie
fille sur tf1 et puis tout d'un coup au
moment où elle a l'expérience et ça
commence à prendre on voit on la
reconnaît en tous les cas c'est le sila
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas ces
moments où ils l'arrêtent
après dans dans la logique de tf1 et
c'est vrai que pour le coup on se prit
sont connus pour avoir franchement
beaucoup de coeur on dit qu'il faut il
faut serrer les coudes et certainement
pas en plein coït qu'il faut annonce à
quelqu'un qui fait plus partie des
meubles et qu'il faut le virer qui a
gagné cette première coupe du monde
des médias est ce que c'est mathieu ou
est-ce que c'est benjamin qui vous a
convaincu
mathieu à 50 2% à ses examens à 40 une
fonction c'est là que tu gagnes sa
première coupe du monde des débats
bonjour vous êtes ravissante delphine
merci on est très content de pouvoir
vous faire gagner peut-être ce soir
jusqu'à 50000 euros à partager en plus
avec la fondation des hôpitaux de paris
et de france et pour jouer avec vous
voilà c'est elle le sait là j'ai pris
pour le début voilà je vous savez
j'avais camille lellouche hier qui est
une de mes comics préférés aujourd'hui
j'ai une de mes chanteuse préférée c'est
ma roue à l'autre qui est avec nous
delphine et toute sa famille
vous repartez ce soir
avec
[Musique]
et comme ça non aujourd'hui dell pèse 5
25000 euros pour toi ma fille et pour ta
famille tes heureusement delphine s'est
tous fait des grands bisous
franchement ça fait tellement plaisir
vous amener du bonheur comme ça au jour
elle peut qu'être du post vous jouez
avec nous bien sûr chez vous bad et vale
vale voila voila j'ai très bien voilà
ra demandé est ce que tu peux demander à
quelqu'un de ta famille dalle étant
préparé un hôte au cas où tu repères
cinéma10 malaisie 2 il recharge de la
batterie basse un shérif d'avoir un
dégât des eaux cellule où je vous le dis
on sera nombreux à envoyer avec
jean-michel merde parce que il faisait
vraiment un puzzle et vous savez jean
michel maire je vous dis la vérité moi
je vous dit tout d'un nichon c'est que
j'ai l'impression d'être son père non
mais sans rigoler arrête arrête voilà
qui est là
voilà voilà il avoue j'aime bien voilà
il me dit non je vous le jure j'ai
l'impression de parler à mon fils mais
je vous jure que c'est vrai et le mans
droit dans les yeux comme si ton
commentaire votre père dans les souris
mais que vous avez remarqué
et on aimerait vous aider on aimerait
que vous parliez à nos téléspectateurs
alors la situation elle est urgente
parce que en fait le le le cycle normal
de l'adoption est interrompue c'est à
dire que nous recueillons des animaux
alors sorti de fourrière lorsque les
animaux sont dix wagons voilà mon chien
lorsque les animaux sont divaguant ils
sont là voilà ils sont chrétiens nous
allan baekke blick parlée par les
fourrières des gardes le temps
d'identifier les propriétaires et au
bout de ses huit jours il ya deux
options ou il le donne à des
associations
mais rien ou comme la société
protectrice des animaux ou alors s'il
n'ya plus d'associations parce qu'il ya
plus de place ils sont obligés d
euthanasie
pour le mot catastrophe prenons les
animaux fort hier parce que c'est notre
rôle nouvelle spa nous les reculeront
nous les éduquons nous les vaccinons
avant de leur trouver une famille
chantier qui va les adopter le problème
c'est comme les gens sont confinés nous
continuerons à remplir nos refuges
nous refusons d'euthanasier aux animaux
statutairement seule interdite on ne
fait jamais ce qui veut dire qu'on a de
plus en plus d'animaux dans nos refuges
mike j'ai un truc à dire parce que je te
jure je pensais à toi mois plus tard
qu'avant-hier alors bien sûr j'ai tous
mes potes que j'adore voilà gad elmaleh
l'invité à part ton époque que j'ai
voilà accusé le voilà que j'ai le plus
aimé recevoir est vraiment que j'ai
adoré dans l'émission c'est toi voilà je
voulais te le diras tu es mon invité
préféré je te le jure j'ai eu un vrai
cirque maxime dans top chef
quel truc un peu relou diego un candidat
qui s'appelle diego at-il fait je crois
que c'est la première et plus et que les
élus et toc
il a planqué des aliments ont un
spécialiste médias c'est pas pour
enfiler des perles
eh ben voilà il a deux galas dégueulasse
et l'assiette de ses adversaires pour
l'instant trois questions trois
mauvaises réponses des génies dans cette
équipe tangue et si tu sors pour
l'instant amg dgac merci mon maxi il ne
reste plus que trois candidats pour ce
jeu le pas payer du post je vous jure
et je vous le dis aux téléspectateurs
s'il n'y en a pas un qui donne une bonne
réponse
et d'ici la fin c'est je prendrai la
décision vous lit personne ne sera payée
lors de la première session de rentrée
et justement matthieu delormeau ses
pompes
matthieu delormeau on va parler du jt de
13h de tf1 il quelle surprise
quelle surprise a reçu jean pierre
pernaut pour son anniversaire en direct
pour son anniversaire en direct mathieu
de l'or alors sans aucun doute c'est là
à la première
pourquoi pas parce que je connais j'ai
regardé que ce travail non parce que je
sens que vous avez le regard à droite là
vous avez regardé quelque chose a fait
très chaud c'est pourquoi je peux vous
montrer parce que je regarde le retour
ici c'est vous l'âge et la télé qu'à ça
je sais pas j'ai coupé le sénat mais
dans un championnat oui mais vous
regarder à gauche
non pas du tout reculé aujourd'hui à des
ratios dorment aussi ça n'est pas la
bonne réponse c'est vous me faites
l'année prochaine vous faites un don
gratuit
je vous laisse une dernière chance de
vous rattraper
mais ça marche pas comme ça cyril les
petites règles à la tunisienne on va
arrêter maintenant tu as posé la
question je réponds je te dise ah c'est
bon c'est pas beau on envoie la réponse
d'un suicide est survenu
vous êtes chez vous que et bravo très
bonne réponse de matthieu delormeau qui
reste et qui sera certainement pas le
pas payé voilà du jour